hey Chava at Sanford wood from Katie Lee
how are you congratulations to you thank
you very much oh this announcement now
of another project with Leonardo mm-hmm
did you guys just have such a great bond
during this one it makes you want to do
something with him again yeah well we
wanted to work together again and we
have the same manager Rick and he was
trying to find another project for us to
acting together and then the story of
Richard Jewell came to us and we were
both so moved by it that uh you know it
was something we both felt like we had
to do and I'm beyond excited for it says
he came up to and said next month yet
wants for another project I wouldn't
care honestly you know work Martin
Scorsese's my favorite filmmaker of all
time you know Goodfellas is the reason I
wanted to make movies with you know
spend my life making movies and dedicate
my life to that and money is never a
concern to work with people like Martin
Scorsese I would do whatever he would
paint his house if he if he asked me to
it's in my safe yes I figured I could
just change a few of the names from the
Moneyball speech but no I I don't know I
the possibility of winning is so is so
insane to me that it seems almost
indulgent to write a speech but I guess
I will just you know in the one in a
billion chance it would happen so I just
so I don't sound stupid you know make
sure and thank my mom and everything
thank you